it was a busy night for red carpets
first up the cast of better call saul
giving us new details about bob
odenkirk's onset heart attack i was
healthy i was able to survive that heart
attack because i had i had veins that
were kind of larger that fed my heart
oxygenated blood when i got uh
cpr one person saved bobby's life her
name's rosa rose estrada absolutely the
paddles were in the car
everybody was
rosa came in once
twice thrice
one person saved his life rosa estrada
is the show's medic who sprang into
action when odenkirk hit the ground in
between takes i didn't think if they
didn't have one of these aed devices
available
that he would have survived it
bob and the cast just wrapped up their
13 episode series finale what can fans
expect when it debuts on amc and amc
plus on april 18th definitely shocking
definitely devastating often hilarious
and there's a lot of cliffhanger moments
coming a lot of excitement so it's a
it's going to be
epic if you stick around long enough
they give you awards and stuff you know
over at the hacks paley fest event gene
smart told us she hasn't seen any of the
episodes of season two that debut in may
on hbo max second seasons are always
scary sure because you feel like
especially if you were a big hit the
first season everybody's going okay just
show me you know kinda
and josh brolin celebrated his new
supernatural western outer range
premiering april 15th on prime video
think of it as yellowstone meets twin
peaks i don't know what it is josh you
know they've got you shirtless in the
trailer i do they they do was that you
who have that interest in my face on
some hot dude it's the first western
josh has done since true grit 11 years
ago the hardest part of being a cowboy
again getting bested by his daughter
yellowstone star eden brolin it was
roping i taught my daughter how to rope
and then i get back into roping and my
daughter sends me instructional videos
back so it's humbling in every way
[Music]
you